[Music]
if you're anything like me you're
probably wondering about current event
topical
issues look at this
map now look at this one t of thousand
of what you probably didn't notice is
that these aren't just Maps they're
images that display the geographical
location of things that exist on Earth
this is Ronald Reagan this is a volcano
this is a little baby my question is how
did we get from here you are going down
to here we might learn the CIA isn't
that bad after all uh hello idiots hello
before we dive into the meat of the
video we must first ask
SpongeBob is he a good neighbor yes this
video was edited on iMovie by the end of
the video we'll have learned how the CIA
killed the Fairly Odd Parents